i like your shirt it seems very
very festive
well this this is such an interesting
film because it feels like this big
concept story
told in such a personal way when you
read this script what did you make of
the world that it creates was it
something that you could visually see
from the beginning did you have a lot of
questions
yeah i mean you know it's quite a kind
of
high concept film isn't it and uh
but yeah also you know i
i i felt this kind of felt like a real
rare gem of the film this and
the questions i was intrigued that this
was a first time
writer first time feature director who i
wanted to meet
and talking with edson and
hearing about his own personal story you
know and what drew him to write this
really on all these basis
le you know i i i wanted to tell this
story with him
[Music]
and uh well i flew out to utah and with
24 days
um with a really committed ensemble and
crew we told this story yeah
i had so many questions about the
details in this from
why is it nine days why are they
watching on these vintage tvs what's
with the vhs
tapes they're all hanging out in this
modest house in the middle of nowhere
did you get answers to those questions
even if we don't
learn them from watching the film did
you learn what those answers were
uh i think i've i've heard in
edson mentioned that about the kind of
the 80s analog thing was a world
that was from winston what winston knew
during his time on earth and then
therefore
that's what was around in his house
i figure but to me that's
someone that's never been alive doesn't
really see
the the kind of memorabilia of of that
you know
but um all i'm concerned about because
he's such a romantic
about life he's just vicariously
looking into these screens and
you know living the lives of others you
know
cherishing others other moments
it seems like a really rare opportunity
to play a character like this
who has never lived before so
where do you start with that how did you
form and shape
who he was and how you wanted to play
him
well started off with a lot of isolation
really i mean when i got there
i i kind of just kept myself to myself
in a room and
didn't really see anybody you know at
all and then and then
and then like keo
he just has an appetite for life
really he he he
needs to feel company he needs to know
everyone's business you know and i think
that's
one of my sort of springboards um
he he's the hope character he's he's the
optimistic
he's yeah he's also the devil's advocate
as well and
he's calling well out on that but um
you know he's for someone that hasn't
lived for someone that hasn't had
anything
like that experience would only want it
more
and then therefore you see him cosplay
you see him kind of dress himself for
the concerto
or or you know stand at weddings you
know
there's a kind of he's the oldest
character but
but also the most innocent as at the
same time so there's lots of sort of
juxtapositions and um
yeah it seems like you'd almost have to
catch yourself not letting your own life
experiences
influence him because he doesn't really
know what that means
yeah yeah yeah but he's kind of
i think he's seen so much before but
yeah he
he's creating he's creating these
experiences
in his own world wherever where whatever
wherever we are in this ether plane you
know
do you think he's someone that wanted to
live does he still
want to have the chance to live is it
something he doesn't even think about or
care about anymore
oh yeah he yearns to live yeah he earns
to
live he's practicing all the time he's
kind of
he's the he's the life yet not lived
you know it's kind of the fulfilled life
yet not lived
and he's he's ready to go i mean
and to some degree that's you know it's
really interesting
[Music]
to to watch you know and i think it kind
of
as as audience members as well you know
people start to see about
what what cherished moments are and that
reflects back to us as
audience members really you know um
you know when we were at sundance there
were kind of
incidents of um
there was an asian family that were
crying and
one more the mother was saying um
i have to go i have to go and call my
son and tell him i love him
and it's like wow it was it was quite
sent chills really because it was like
this the story of the film was
running off and permeating into audience
members you know
when you work on a project with someone
from the mcu like winston duke
on something that's outside of that
marvel world like this film
is is there a special connection there
do you all sort of feel like you're part
of one big family whether you've shared
much time in the marvel universe or not
yeah with what well i i met winston the
premier of
doctor strange and you know he came over
and said hey you don't know me i'm once
the duke i'm
doing this thing a part in black panther
and i didn't know what black panther was
and then and then further down the line
i
didn't know what power panther was and i
did not
when said duke was and and then we were
running around in
uh infinity war or was it endgame and
uh during the big charge always
constantly having a laugh with him
and then just to finally getting a
chance to be working with him was
was was great and it was it was a
different experience you know definitely
because
you know he had to certainly go to
a different space really you know um
it was uh if not it was just con it was
emanating heaviness you know uh
rightly so but it was like you know the
crew were just kind of
um heavily you know even
even the crew were feeling depressed and
as soon as they saw me they
they saw this lavity beacon and it was
like come over here
um but um everyone had their role to
play
and yeah and yeah he's fantastic
it took a bit longer for doctor strange
too to get into production than folks
originally expected but it sounds like
it's going to be
well worth the wait so without spoilers
what was your reaction
to reading the script and learning about
what's in store
should we you know already be getting
excited about it
you should be getting excited um
um what can i say not a lot like usually
i can't say anything can i do states
well just the thing
you had from reading the script um
oh it's it's a cracking script and then
now to have
having um sam raimi involved has been uh
it's been a really wonderful experience
you know he's such a fantastic director
a lovely lovely man um
we're kind of well we know when they're
he's he's such he's just such fun
to work with and we always have a
yeah we always yeah i like throwing
alts and he just he likes them
so it's kind of you know we kind of just
have a bit of a laugh with this i mean
like i just
throw anything at the wall and sometimes
it'll fall down
and then like sometimes it'll stick and
then like but that's it just constant
keep
that's amazing isn't it it's the
creative process
and uh if you're not as long as you're
not afraid to throw
something at wall you know it might be
right might be wrong you know and
but yet we're all just we're all just
trying to
kind of you know make something here but
um yeah we're having a lot of fun and
then i'm finishing
that off in september so um so we're
nearly there
you're also in shanghai which a lot of
people including myself are excited
about
what does it mean to you to be a part of
the first marvel movie
with an asian cast and asian superheroes
yeah um well yeah the first leading
asian superhero and sema
[Music]
i you know it's just it's the asians
assemble uh it's the kind of
yeah to to have uh tony lung and
[Music]
you know kofina ronnie chang who else is
there
manga um chen
it feels very very exciting you know i
mean i i mean
i've seen that trailer many many times
you know um
and uh it was um
yeah i'm very excited about it you know
yeah
i love filmmakers i love all the
filmmakers you're working with
sam raimi's a personal favorite of mine
but
i think the work that edson does with
this film is
just so beautiful what was that
collaboration like with him throughout
the film i mean did you guys
communicate a lot or was it rehearsals
ahead of time and then he just
sort of you know stepped back when
you're on set together how did that
experience work with him as a first-time
filmmaker
very collaborative always there for a
zoom always there for a chat
or just to give you great clarity
of where you want to go with your
character and
um deeper discussions and then even
even being on set you know it's such a
calming influence
great leader um
you know a real phenomenal talent you
know you just don't
it's just yeah you keep i keep saying
about this first time
feature director but he's just he's
already quite lived in now
already and what he can say
um visually and communicate is really
stunning just
you know where you know like i think the
first
um 10 minutes is the there's
there's no words and there's just action
that speak louder and um as it
draws you into the world into the world
and it's just
you know we're there to get audience
audiences
thinking and asking questions
there is an ambiguity to it and
yeah high price for him real talent
did you think about what happens to keo
after we last see him in in the film do
you think that
will will have changed in any way or
things will be different in any way for
these people
yeah who knows this is yeah who knows
yeah well you you've kind of
yeah it's kind of ambiguous isn't it you
know what what happens to him after
after after he you know i guess
awakens really i don't know
yeah i just thought that was so
interesting i mean obviously there's
that turning point moment for
will that it just made me wonder like
what what is
keo gonna do now that that has happened
so
yeah yeah that's we'll have to wait for
ten days
yeah well also i i appreciate you
talking about this i just thought
the subject matter was so beautifully
handled it seems like it could have gone
wrong
so many different ways with another
filmmaker so
yeah it was just fascinating to watch oh
great
thank you thanks uh thank you for
watching the movie i mean all
we want is people to kind of go in there
with
hey no expectations and just kind of
sit back and be a captive audience and
just allow this
this concept you know this the these
questions there and
to see what to see what happens and how
that reflects to you as an audience
member
you know well and thank you for bringing
the fun to it because it might have
gotten a little
little dark and depressing otherwise at
least you've had some fun with it
thanks cheers thank you